madame monsieur bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous comme dans ces grandes
circonstances toutes les grandes soirées
électorales que vous suivez en notre
compagnie ce soir spécial élections
régionales jusqu'aux alentours de 22h15
22h30 toute l'équipe de france
démobilisés rédaction moyens techniques
dans les principales villes de france
dans les principales régions qui sont en
question ce soir avec des résultats
serrés attendu à 20 heures une grande
estimations nationales et une projection
sur l'ensemble des régions
pour l'instant le seul chiffre qui soit
à notre disposition c'est celui de
l'abstention une abstention record pour
ce type d'élection 40 2,5 % d'abstention
c'est un chiffre énorme qui va semble
compliqué pas mal de choses à partir de
20 heures
en 1992 ou loyers ce pourcentage n'était
que de 31,3 et en 1997 si vous voulez
encore comparer là c'était le premier
tour des élections législatives 31,5
dont 40 2 5 % d'abstention c'est un
chiffre qui va avoir son importance ce
soir à partir de 20h arlette chabot oui
effectivement on savait que ce scrutin
ces élections avaient un peu beaucoup
passionné les français l'avaient bien
senti pendant la campagne mais c'est
vrai que ce niveau d'abstention est
extrêmement fort il faut retrouver un
chiffre comparable aux alentours de 1994
c'était pour des élections cantonales
c'était donc un scrutin le cas
légalement et 94
c'était un an après les législatives de
93 là nous sommes et bien neuf mois
après d'autres élections importantes
l'enjeu national aussi d'autres
législatif ce qui explique peut-être le
peu de mobilisation des français en tout
cas vous avez raison de dire que c'est
un chiffre extrêmement important car il
a non sans doute des résultats très
serrés pour ces régionales de ce soir
merci arlette donc à partir de 19h40
compte se quittent plus jusqu'aux
alentours de 22h30 avec l'estimation et
les projections dès 20h ipsos bull sur
votre antenne sur france 2 pour
l'instant le journal berrichonne bergues
madame monsieur bonsoir je vous propose
d'ouvrir ce journal avec ses photos
instantanées devant l'isoloir ce matin à
sarran en corrèze
le présidente
la république jacques chirac accompagné
de son épouse a contenu son devoir
électoral
accueilli par les applaudissements de
plusieurs dizaines d'habitants le couple
présidentiel s'est prêtée avec bonne
grâce aux traditionnelles photos madame
chirac est candidate dans le canton de
corrèze un quatrième mandat consécutif
de conseillère générale et puis c'est en
début d'après midi que lionel jospin est
arrivé à sa langue a bel chef lieu du
canton le premier ministre se présente
pour un troisième mandat devant la
presse venue en nombre assister au vote
lionel jospin pour les régionales après
tout les buts sauf celui du front
national avant de se rendre dans
l'isoloir lionel jospin qui devrait
faire tout à l'heure une déclaration
depuis la salle des fêtes de
cintegabelle et puis en fin d'après midi
au siège de la campagne de la gauche
plurielle rue de turbigo à paris
opération très médiatique d'une
quarantaine de personnes se réclamant
des associations de chômeurs ils ont
envahi les locaux devant les caméras et
les photographes
pendant ce temps là toujours à paris
quelque 140 100 papillon d'occuper et
l'église notre dame de la garde dans le
xiiie arrondissement
tous réclament la libération de l'un des
leurs et des papiers pour tous ceux qui
ne les ont pas encore obtenu une vie
galzi emmanuel bec et l'as rome à
l'appel du 6e collectif des sans-papiers
ils sont plus d'une centaine en majorité
africains à avoir investi l'église notre
dame de la garde
ce qu'ils réclament la libération de
l'un des leurs en situation irrégulière
et puis aussi des papiers pour tous
aider dans leur combat par les anciens
de l'église saint bernard
nous sommes là parce que ça fait deux
ans qu'on est sorti de l'ombre
jusqu'à présent on a des camarades qui
sont restés sur le carreau
il n'y a pas de raison des luttes et
avec des gens pendant des années mais
lindsay tomber
et le combat il continue on a toujours
dit quelqu'un qui reste à la lutte de
saint-bernard ça continue pour l'heure
une soixantaine de policiers se contente
de bloquer l'accès à l'église dans une
église un immense le midi
monseigneur gaillot ne pourra donc pas
rencontrer le prêtre de la paroisse
lequel s'est d'ailleurs enfermé dans
l'église à l'intérieur aussi certains
sans papiers se recueillaient dans cette
fin de journée dans cette église ou pour
tout le monde ce soir
la nuit sera longue deuxième jour
d'occupation wavre de l'église saint
pierre une vingtaine de sans papiers
originaires ont la plupart d'afrique
loin se sont installés dans une seule
près de la nef où diverses associations
comme assez on râle font leur ont
apportés et nourriture et matelassée
manifestants demandent la régularisation
de leur situation ils sont tous
installés au havre et leur porte-parole
à sommes leur détermination à aller
jusqu'au bout
occupation toujours dans la capitale
cette fois ci une quinzaine de chômeurs
ont pénétré dans un ancien hôtel du
xviiième arrondissement ce matin
banderole sur la façade les chômeurs
serait soutenu par diverses associations
dont act up et droits devant
ou encore la ligue des droits de l'homme
ce soir les forces de police continuait
d'entourer le bâtiment dans l'actualité
de ce jour l'accident d'un autocar
transportant des enfants dans les
pyrénées-orientales neuf jeunes ont été
blessés quatre restent hospitalisés
apparemment le chauffeur a eu des
problèmes de freins et a préféré percuté
la falaise pour éviter de tomber dans le
précipice
le saint-siège confirme bien la
publication demain d'un document sur la
shoah et la responsabilité du
christianisme document que le pape avait
promis il y a dix ans à la communauté
juive del annonce de sa parution
les réactions se multiplient l'attenté
grande est l'un des collaborateurs le
plus proche de jean paul ii affirme que
l'indifférence des chrétiens a facilité
le low cost
olivier l'une usa et marc maisonneuve
jusqu'où ira-t-il jusqu'où ira jean paul
ii dans son geste à l'égard de la
communauté juive
aujourd'hui l'un de ses plus proches
collaborateurs a admis que
l'indifférence des chrétiens envers les
juifs a facilité le low cost poteev avec
hitler a pu commettre ces crimes
une plus facilement il n'y a pas eu une
sensibilité suffisant des chrétiens une
conscience de nos devoirs envers les
juifs
et c'est ainsi que nous avons toléré
plus facilement les cris contre les bras
levé définitivement les ambiguïtés sur
le silence de l'église catholique
la communauté juive attend à mea culpa
ceux qui n'ont pas pardonné généralement
son bord et donc ils sont plus en état
d' accorder leur pardon
ce que j'attends de l'église c'est un
mea culpa par rapport à elles mêmes par
rapport à sa doctrine par rapport à la
morale que prétend et qu'elle veut
représenter ces salles le par danser un
pardon de l'église par rapport à dieu
vraisemblablement et aux crises pour ce
qu'elle a fait de mal le document du
vatican publié demain entre dans le
cadre ne lis jamais de conscience auquel
le pape a invité les chrétiens un examen
de conscience afin de purifier l'église
avant son entrée dans le troisième
millénaire aux états unis nouveaux
développements dans la sphère paula
jones aujourd'hui le nom d'une nouvelle
stagiaire de la maison blanche étoffe un
peu plus le dossier scandale qui n'en
finit pas d'éclabousser le président
clinton et puis ce soir
témoignage très attendu d'une femme de
54 ans qui a donné une longue interview
à l'une des grandes chaînes de
télévision dans laquelle elle affirme
avoir fait l'objet d' avance déplacer
philippe gassot dans la série stagiaire
de la maison blanche on demande
maintenant kathleen c'est elle qui s'est
tenue à la télévision va par ethnie le
faire d'importantes révélations qui
pourraient bien placé le président
partie respirer à cames des vides dans
une position un peu plus difficile
encore catherine ouellet par laquelle le
scandale pourrait bien rebondir a
indiqué clairement dans une déposition
que le pré
dans avait eu avec elle des gestes en
dessous de la ceinture
on ne peut plus déplacés mais là n'est
pas le tout dernier épisode il ya une
autre jeune femme
sheridan choque encore inconnue jusqu
alors qu'ils auraient elles aussi des
choses à tenir
l'avocat de paula jones donovan campbell
qui ne veut pas voir classer la sphère
où ça la roue avec son dossier de 700
pages largement distribué qui permet à
la presse de se déchaîner
de son côté l'avocat numéro un du
président rob bennett considère il n'ya
dans tout cela une volonté de nuire bill
clinton mais rien de solide
juridiquement je pense que vous allez
tous à prendre le 27 mai prochain jour
du procès ce que les six ou sept cents
pages
c'est un peu comme de la barbe à papa
quand vous mettez dedans il n'y a plus
rien faire existe pas quant à paula
jones elle exulte on la voit partout où
elle est soutenue par les ennemis
politiques du président les républicains
dont les catholiques purs et durs
défenseurs de la vertu bafoués elle elle
a attendu que son agresseur sexuel passe
de la fonction de gouverneur de
l'arkansas à celle de président d des
produits pour mettre son honneur dans la
balance
confiné dans le silence bill clinton
encore préau dans les sondages pourrait
bien se retrouver la semaine prochaine
dans une situation très délicat aux
etats unis toujours une nouvelle
chronique des amours interdites de cette
institutrice américaine condamnée à sept
ans de prison pour avoir eu une liaison
avec un élève âgé de 13 ans un enfant
est né de cette passion aujourd'hui
mary kay letourneau serait à nouveau
enceinte de l'adolescent qu'elle aurait
revu avant d'être emprisonné en février
dernier alain douguet sq
c'était l'an dernier cette jeune femme
souriante à son enfant jusque là rien
d'extraordinaire
pourtant elle ira certainement prison en
effet le père de l'enfant est mineur il
a 13 ans nous ne verrons donc pas son
visage
cette femme est accusée d'avoir violé
jeune homme jugé au mois de novembre
dernier elle était condamnée à sept
années de prison avec sursis et devait
se repentir publiquement ce qu'elle a
fait
remise en liberté le juge exige donc
d'elle qu'elle ne revoit plus le père de
son enfant
mais profitant de sa liberté elle
retrouve le jeune homme et tombe de
nouveau enceinte
elle est donc rejugée actuellement elle
affirme aimer son amant à la folie lui
soutient qu'il était consentant ce que
de grossesse donnerait bien approuvé la
justice américaine ne l'entend pas ainsi
et accuse l'institutrice le déviant
sexuel
c'est aujourd'hui que les pilotes de
l'avion militaire qui a provoqué en
février dernier le drame du téléphérique
en italie ces pilotes sont arrivés aux
états unis pour y être jugé
ils passeront devant la cour martiale
washington ayant refusé de laisser la
justice italienne jugée la sphère au
kosovo plus de vingt mille personnes ont
défilé silencieusement dans le centre de
pristina à la mémoire des victimes de la
répression serbe les manifestants
arboraient des portraits de mère teresa
qui est d'origine albanaise
d'autres faisaient lé v de la victoire
peu de policiers sur le parcours du
sport à présent le belge frank
vandenbroucke a remporté aujourd'hui
sous le soleil
la 65e édition du paris-nice au terme de
la dernière étape
cet après midi remportée au sprint par
le français christophe capelle au
classement général frank vandenbroucke
devance laurent jalabert triple
vainqueur de l'épreuve
et puis pour alberto tomba la star
mondialement reconnu du ski une 50e
victoire avec aujourd'hui le slalom des
finales de la coupe du monde
la bomba comme on l'appelle n'a pas
boudé son plaisir christophe sur terrain
pour sa dernière apparition des skis aux
pieds alberto tomba voulait absolument
réussir sa sortie
honnêtement c'est fait
ce matin crans montana il a remporté le
dernier slalom de coupe du monde de la
saison probablement son dernier stallone
vous dire que l'événement l'a laissé de
glace serait mentir
une fois débarrassé de ses skis donner à
ses admirateurs ils nous ont offert un
dernier tour de piste
et dans le genre commedia dell arte la
bamba s'y connaît le palmarès d'alberto
lui vaut bien d'être porte entrions 50
du port en coupe du monde
une collection médaille olympique tomba
et le skieur le plus titré de l'histoire
alberto va désormais pouvoir se
consacrer à son nouveau métier
finalement pas si différent du précédent
il compte faire l'acteur et vous en
conviendrez il est assez doué un dernier
strip tease pour le plaisir des yeux
devant une foule en délire
n'en jetez plus alberto on a assez
aujourd'hui à paris défilé de la
collection de valentino et donc garraud
tous deux jouent la féminité à outrance
et le luxe en demi teinte pour l'un des
couleurs éclatantes pour l'autre le
clair-obscur nicole cornu langlois
jacques girard après une semaine de
collection dominée par l'ascétisme et le
minimalisme le défilé des manhwas ni
garou apparaît tout à coup comme un
havre de tendresse de volupté avec la
fluidité des étoffes et d'efforts la
sensualité d'une robe cuit roulant le
port le visage adoucie par des cols en
fourrure ou le confort d'un ample
manteau sur une robe de soie brodée le
classicisme du pied de poule
réinventer dans une robe manteau doublé
de soi poids provocation et romantisme
élégance sans complaisance
une collection qui a soulevé
l'enthousiasmé l'envié étrange pour
ballantyne long cardigan de cachemire
macramé et jupe en crêpe gros pulls
style irlandais rebrodée de platine
leurustic s'allie au raffinés une
collection qui reflète dans 100 modèles
un monde de silence mais sans
ostentation du luxe certes mais façon
décontractée confortable plutôt discrète
avec parfois l'arrogance de robots
flamboyante
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
remercie de votre attention
rendez vous dans une dizaine de minutes
pour la soirée spéciale élections
bonsoir
vous